من جديد تستيقظ كياف ومدن اوكرانيه اخرى
على وقع هجوم صاروخيا روسيا واسع النطاق
هو الاعنف منذ عده اسابيع واستهدف وفق
السلطات هناك منشات حيويه ومناطق مدنيه
تقول هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان دفاعاتها
الجويه اسقطت 54 صاروخا روسيا من اصل 69
استهدفت عده مقاطعه في البلاد كان من
بينها مدينه ليفيف القريبه من الحدود مع
بولندا حيث تسببت الهجمات الصاروخيه على
منشات الطاقه فيها بحرمان نحوه 90% من
سكانها من الكهرباء على الجانب الاخر
اعلنا حاكم مقاطعه الروسيه ان الدفاعات
الجويه هناك اعترضت ما وصفها باهداف
مجهوله فوق قاعده الجويه حيث توجد
القاذفات الاست خليجيه بعيده المدى وهذه
هي المره الثانيه خلال ثلاثه ايام التي
تعلن فيها السلطات الروسيه صدم محاوله
الاستهداف القاعده اذ سبق ان اعلنت مقتل
ثلاثه جنود هناك في سقوط حطام مسيره
اوكرانيه في السادس والعشرين من الشهر
الجاري
على جبهات التماس شرقيه اوكرانيا تواصلت
الاشتباكات على اكثر من محور في مقاطعه
الزبرجها اعلن الجيش الاوكراني تمكنه من
استهداف عشرات من الجنود الروس وتدميرين
مركز القياده واخر للاتصالات خلال غارات
شنتها مقاتله اوكرانيه على مواقع تمركز
القوات الروسيه
اما في دنيه فقالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انها اسقطت مقاتلتين ومروحيتين اوكرانيتين
كما تمكنت من تدمير راجمه الصواريخ من
طرازي هاي مارس الامريكيه في حين اتهمت
السلطات المواليه لروسيا هناك القوات
الاوكرانيه باستهداف العديد من الاحياء
السكنيه القذائف ما اوقع عددا من الضحايا
في صفوف المدنيين في حين بدا لافتا اعلان
بلا روسيا ان دفاعاتها الجويه
اسقطت صاروخا اوكرانيا من منظومه اس 300
داخل اراضي البلاد في حادثه هي الاولى من
نوعها منذ اندلاع الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا